that question as I have trouble fighting a comfortable sleeping position is okay to position the
right bulb under your pillow um yes you can it partly depends on where your cancer is technically
you want the right is close to your cancer as possible if you're lying on your side put the put the
bulb behind you or in front of you I still think it's probably better at getting your whole body more
if it's more by your side it doesn't have to be touching you remember if it's within six to 12 inches
that's great if it if you are stuggling with it it is touching you that's better but don't worry if
it falls if you move around and you have to set it by your side or whatever don't worry about that if
you put it under your pillow it's mainly um yeah I mean it's I I guess you can I wouldn't think that
it would be highly uncomfortable but um if you're putting if you're thinking to put it on that
you're putting it under your pillow and it's above your head so it's not affected your
flexion of your neck um and your lower dorses of your cervical spine then I would say
that it's getting farther away from you so um but whatever works if that works better that's I think
that's fine too